Good morning everyone and welcome to AIPCON 8. My
name is Jack Dobson, AIP lead here at Palanteer
and it's my absolute pleasure to welcome you to
the show. For those of you that are returning,
welcome back. Those of you that are new to
the show, thank you so much for joining us.
We have a great morning's content lined up
for you. A whole set of customer keynotes,
including also our CEO, Dr. Karp, taking to
the stage. But before any of that, we have a
very special pre-show to kick off the show. I am
delighted to be joined with two of my colleagues
from Andretti Global. We've got Zack Porter,
senior simulation engineer within Indie Car,
and then Carl Kirkwood, Indie Car driver with
the team. Thank you so much, guys, for joining
me. Thank you for having us. Awesome. So, we're
going to be kicking off the show with a little
bit of a run through and actually a launch of the
partnership between Palanteer and Andretti. We're
going to be showcasing some of the work we've been
building over just the last few weeks and setting
a vision for what we're going to go and achieve in
2026. So with that, let's hop into a little demo
and we're going to actually drive all of this by
showcasing some of the work we've been building
together. Perhaps Zach, do you want to kick us
off? Introduce us to the world of Indie Car,
the world of Andretti, and kind of the beginnings
of our partnership. Yeah, so Indie Car is uh it's
11 teams. It's 27 full-time entries, 33 at
the Indy500. We compete on road courses,
street courses, short ovals, speedways, this
massive amount of data, this massive different
kinds of racing and all across the globe uh with
massive number of variables. Uh and and all that
we have to work together to make decisions in in
in real time really really really quickly between
sessions. Um it it's quite a challenge. That's
incredible. And obviously I mean as with a lot
of the challenges we face out in the field like
this is a heavy data challenge, right? So Carl,
for you I'm curious like as we think about
we're going to be talking a lot about data,
a lot about workflows and things like that. As the
race weekend progresses, like how is it for you?
Like what's the progression of the weekend? How do
you think about the technology and the data you're
working with? And I guess what's the experience
from the driver side of all of this? Yeah, I
mean there's so much to experience and and I don't
even know where to start if I'm being honest, but
um as a driver you don't get a lot of time to to
look over things. you are um between media events,
you're driving the car, you're or meeting with
sponsors, um partners, uh whoever it might be,
and you get a very short period to actually focus
on the data that's in front of you. And um you're
you're typically always trying to find lap time.
You're always looking at sectors. You're looking
at uh speed traces, throttle traces, brake traces,
steering traces, and and trying to understand
where you can find lap time because ultimately
everything leading up into the race is is all
about just how can you make a car go as fast as
possible around a single lap or a single sector.
So for us, it's it's focusing on that, trying to
find exactly how we can optimize the corners, the
speeds, everything um for a driver standpoint, but
also for the car. So, um, it's really important
and and we like like Zach just said, we have so
much data to look at and it's crucial to pinpoint
and find exactly what you need, but there's also
so many variables, right? So, a lot of times
you'll look at a a portion of data and then you
also need to um compare it to another portion of
data and you kind of just keep falling down rabbit
holes um trying to understand things and there's
always questions and we always run out of time and
that that's ultimately our our sport, right? It's
time. It's it's time on the racetrack. It's time
looking at data. It's time in in every format. So,
um it's important to get through it quickly to to
optimize everything. That's incredible. I mean, as
you say, it's as much a race off track as it is on
track. Right. Exactly. Like that is the challenge
we're fundamentally solving. So, great segue into
the problems we're solving together, right? So,
this is race OS. This is what we've been building
over just the last few weeks, right? The last
handful of races as we closed out the 2025
season. Congrats again in the championship. That's
incredible. Um Zach, do you want to kind of tee up
this demo a little bit? talk us through race and
we'll also talk through a little bit about how we
actually went about building this as well. Yeah,
so race here is like a it's a central point for
all the work we do between sessions. So we have,
you know, everything from a quick snapshot of
timing and scoring. In the bottom left corner,
maybe some actions uh in the bottom right there
of of sensor anomalies or some things that come
up that we need to take action on. You know,
in the top right, we have weather information,
a countdown to the next session, um outings along
the left hand side, and then a series of of apps
along the left that are all the workflows that
we need to work through to get from where we are
right now and make decisions for the next session.
100%. And as always, like with any race, this is
now just a timing game to see how long it takes
me to say the word ontology. And that is exactly
what we're going to start by talking about. So
obviously everything with regards to race OS,
everything we've built is built on Andrett's
unique ontology, right? That is the coalescing
of the data, the logic, the actions that make up
the team and every single decision you make off
and on track. So maybe like Zach, talk me talk
to me a little bit about the kind of systems
that you're working with, how you work with data
within the team, and I guess what were some of
those challenges that we went in to go and solve?
Yeah, I mean part of the big problem we have is we
we have a ton of data and we're really good with
data. We have a ton of tools and we've been doing
this a very long time as as my colleagues say
we we're big data before big data was a thing
sometimes uh and we're really good at that but
it it sits in silos and it sits in buckets and
it sits in in unconnected ways. So timing and
scoring comes from Indie car but you know data and
telemetry comes from the car and those two things
are not directly connected in any way. And what
Foundaries allowed us to do is is create those
connections to all these like unique individual
buckets of of data and serve them all up in one
way and in in relationships that make sense. Yeah,
100%. So that's obviously where it starts, right?
You start with the data component of that sort
of holy trinity. So this is our broader ontology.
This is the circuitry behind the entirety of race
and as we dive in, we'll see that data component
to begin with. So you can see obviously we're not
thinking about spreadsheets. We're not thinking
about data sets. We're thinking about the the
sort of concepts and the entities you work with
on a day-to-day basis, right? You got the tracks,
the drivers, the sessions, lap times, performance.
Like this basically allows the team to stop
thinking about, oh, where do I need to go to get
to that information and instead everything is
connected, contextualized. So, I mean, Zach, kind
of what's your thoughts around how this is going
to speed up operations for the team? For us, we we
need to serve like kind like kind like kind like
kind like kind like kind like kind like kind like
kind like kind like kind of like Kyle said too,
we need to serve all of these disparate pieces of
data up in one way to allow our race engineers and
performance engineers and systems engineers to
make decisions quicker. So as we connect these
things, you know, tracks to sectors to sessions
to timing to setups to all the important pieces
of our puzzle if we can serve them up in one
way and present them to our race engineers,
we can be more informed to make better decisions
sooner. 100%. And I think that's also where AIP
comes in, right? The ability to not only just
have the data, but also then start adding logic,
layering logic on top of that information so
we can actually start getting closer to driving
decisions, right? KL, I'm curious for you like if
you put yourself in the position of you've just
come straight off track, right? you're in that
time between sessions. I've seen you you sit down
in the engineering truck, you sit with the team
and start digging through what just happened,
right? What did we learn? How to improve for the
next session. Talk me through some of that process
in your mind. Like what kind of things do you want
to see? How do you go about sort of evaluating
what just happened? Well, it it solely depends
on how you do in a session, of course. Um, but I
would say in in general, you're always looking at
teammates data and um, there's many many sensors
that we can look at as as drivers comparative
to to our teammates. We get raw data from there,
but you also look at telemetry, GPS data from
other cars that we can also get from from the
series. And um, you kind of use both of those
along with some some video as well. You kind of
go back to the raw formats of of things, right?
where you're just looking at offtrack video,
um, car on boards from the broadcast even. Um,
just a combination of many things that if you're
looking for one piece of you, you typically start
with the data. You start with the data compared to
teammates or data compared to another car and then
you find that and you're like, okay, what's going
on here? Why why do we need to find pace here?
And then you translate that into video, um, oncar
or incar footage, I should say, um, broadcast
footage, whatever it might be. and then you try
and just put the whole picture together. Um, so
you're always just bouncing around from a lot of
different things to to find out exactly what you
need for pace in the race car. And and our our job
with that on the engineering side is to take his
sensations and his view and the things his talents
in the race car and turn that into data and and
find actions in the data that back up what he said
and helps us understand with context the the level
of of under steer that we need to fix or the level
of power down problems or whatever it might be.
So we can um make a datadriven decision to to help
him go faster. Makes total sense. And that action
component exactly is the next piece of this,
right? The ontology is it's data, it's logic,
but it's also the ability to take action on that
information as well. So a lot of what we've been
building is really kind of empowering your team,
right? Like we're not looking to replace people
like you guys, as you said, are extremely adept
at working with this data. This is about getting
the right data into users hands quicker. And these
applications you see on the screen is just a
subset of all the apps we've built, right? Like
tell me more Zach about like some of the pace
that you've seen and actually building this
out. We've been working together for a handful of
weeks, right? Yeah. I mean truly we spent about I
don't know 5 days getting all the different data
sources connected and and and streaming in and
then from there we've we've had some use cases
with our systems engineers for example just fall
out and and build something uh that they can take
action on in like 24 hours. That's the that's the
power of this whole thing is once we get all the
data in, once we once we understand really what
the end goals are, some some applications just
kind of fall out of the bottom and usefulness
just comes right away. That's incredible. So,
speaking of that, we're sort of in the context
now of we are 30 minutes, just over 30 minutes
out from the race. We're thinking about car setup,
right? Like that's step one of this. How do we
start applying everything we've learned not just
this weekend, but also previous weekends at
the same track. How do we pull that together
to start configuring the car to perform as best as
possible on track? So what we see here is actually
we're looking at one particular setup that we've
run in the past and you can see we've even got
our own Kyle represented in the ontology but we've
also got your performance on track your laps your
segment times as you mentioned and of course even
your commentary there so every driver comment we
get every engineering change made as a result of
those comments it's all captured that ontology and
this view I actually kind of like the ability
to see like if we focus in on Kyle you can see
all of that context that with just one click you
can jump to right so I mean Zach how would this
have worked in the past like if you wanted to jump
from Kyle to like show me every race, every timing
performance, every sector. Like what would that
have looked like previously for a while? That's
really difficult. Um yeah, in the past, you know,
we we have like a setup database that has setups
that have been run that is broken down across
tracks and years and and sessions and drivers and
uh you know, then a different database that has
timing and scoring information. And so you'd have
to one by one in all these different programs,
go to different places and try and drill down to
find, you know, there's not even an easy way to
search like, hey, what's the fastest we've ever
been around this track? uh you kind of have to
just know that and then go to that session and
find that setup and find that information and then
navigate somewhere else to find all the timing and
scoring data and navigate to a different program
to find all the time series data that's associated
with that and that's what we're trying to make
those connections here. Yeah, makes total sense
and I think that's also a good segue there of
like you mentioned you just have to sort of
know that that kind of intuition you're running
on. So the way I've certainly thought about it
is like how do we bring more of the data backing
more of the actual like datadriven insights and
actions beyond just ins uh the sort of intuition
that you guys have built because obviously you've
got a ton of experience but this is about backing
it up with the right data and also identifying
the things that you may have missed right like
what are those things kind of in the gaps in the
noise that you may not have otherwise spotted so I
guess Carl for you as well like as you think about
working with this data and say you're literally
30 minutes out from a race session like where's
your mind at and also what are you thinking
about what do I need to know to perform as
good as best as possible in this next session?
Well, I mean that that's a great question,
right? It depends which session you're going into,
but I'd say into the race, we're we're focused a
lot on the actual strategy of the race and how is
it going to play out? How can we run the fastest,
say 80 laps from from the green flag to the
checkered? And and a lot of that comes down
to tire de uh fuel saving uh performance. When
when is the car fast? When is the car slow? How
is traffic going to be involved in your race? How
how are um at what point are pit stops going to
be the the fastest time to to to optimize your
race? Right? So you're you're there's a lot of
variables that that you're trying to pull together
and you're trying to understand it, but a lot of
things change as the race um progresses, right?
So understanding how um the race progresses and
how things may change also dictates a lot of of
how you're ultimately going to end up in a race,
right? And um trying to understand those things
is extremely important. Yeah, 100%. And and Zach,
we were talking about this earlier, but I think
as we look at this view on the screen now, we've
actually like the system AIP has assisted us with
finding four potential setups that we can compare,
right? I think the cool thing about this
is when we start to layer in AIP as well,
you start pulling out some of those proactive
insights of here are the things that have happened
in the past, things that you may have forgotten,
yellow flag in that session or that person going
off track or whatever it is. What the system
can actually do is pull all of that information
together alongside the setup data to actually
contextualize it with performance information with
session information beyond just trying to remember
why did we run that setup. You now have everything
at your fingertips, right? So talk me through how
you're thinking about this helping the team in the
future. Yeah, I mean this particular view here has
as along the left the fastest lap we've ever run
around and the setup associated with it that we've
ever run around Long Beach in this particular
case. Uh and in the in the previous slide, we were
searching for something, you know, a setup change
that maybe Kyle or or Jeremy as race engineer
have gone through and something that they want
to explore for this next session. And this AIP
has has gone through and found inside our database
three setups that are very similar to that change
that they wanted to make and all the associated
data that is that that's with that. So we have the
setup differences that are listed here and then
down below there's also the key metrics that are
associated with that. Um and it's it's it's quite
a powerful tool to really quickly drill down. We
we had no way to do this before. No way of like
making a setup change or proposing a setup change
and then understanding all the things that go
along with that that we've ever done historically.
That's a brand new tool for us. That's awesome.
That's incredible. So, I think what we're going
to see now is obviously that was all the setup
information that we quite rightly have hidden from
the audience a little bit. We don't want to give
away the secret source, but you can see all of
those parameters, right? The difference here, the
deltas from session to session. This is all well
and good like it's useful seeing that comparison,
but I think it's then how do you actually apply
logic on top of that, right? It's not just show me
the delta, but show me maybe some of the context
behind some of that delta, right? Like why did
you make those decisions? Yeah, each each of those
setups were run in different years and different
sessions in different conditions. Uh, and the
ability for AIP to go through and and provide the
context like we see here on the left. So that's
a specific setup picked, but then it provides
the story of how we got there. So each outing in
that session that led up to this, its performance
relative to the field, which is the second part
we see there. Uh, and then its comparison to the
reference, the fastest time we've ever gone around
that racetrack. and what things are different and
what things sort of tell the story of why this
is maybe a good direction to go or maybe why
it's a bad direction to go. Exactly. And talk me
through I know I've heard you in the truck a few
times be like I remember we did this last year
or I remember we ran this setup or something like
that. Like are you often just going off like
oh what did we do last time what worked? What
didn't? Like how do you think this would change
maybe your flow getting ready for a session?
You know it's extremely interesting looking at at
some of this stuff right and and talking about it
beforehand in this in this pre-show. It's there's
a lot of bins in in silos as you said that that
information um topics, setups, everything is kind
of spread out and we're always finding that we
have to go to a different folder, a different a
different area or a different server to to find
things that we want. And simplifying it and
putting it all in one spot saves us so much
time. And I go back to the time that it that our
our whole motorsports career is about. counts,
you know, every minute counts. Off the track, on
the track, everything is is important and it just
it allows us to make more educated decisions um
with with valid information. That's awesome. So,
I think what we're going to do now is we're
going to segue. So, like this was all pre-race,
right? Like we're looking ahead of Long Beach,
which was a race of the season, which actually
Carl won. Not to give away the lead there. Um but
I think what's important is okay, great. We've got
our setup down. We can obviously capture that
in the ontology. Then we transition to postra,
right? Like so obviously we get the car ready,
we optimize the setup going into the session.
That's all well and good. What you can see here is
we're actually capturing all of that those setup
decisions and all the edits that have been made in
the ontology. So it's you're continually adding to
those breadcrumbs, right? Like adding to the asset
that you have to draw upon next time. I think
where this gets particularly exciting is when we
start to get into the more telemetrydriven stuff,
right? As we start to think about sensors,
how the car is performing. So, as we now
kind of transition to that post-race, you can see
there KL, you're you're at the top of the timing
stands. That's pretty good. Um, now the next
stage is like, well, what worked, what didn't,
how did the car perform, and what can we learn
from for next time. And I think we've built some
pretty cool stuff around session review. So,
Zach, talk me through some of the behind the
scenes of how we went around building this and I
guess also like how's this compare to how you guys
work with particularly tire information and tire
sensor based data today. Yeah, when when we get
to post session, we have this dump of data that's
arrived in all these different forms. Uh and and
all of them represent a performance or a piece of
performance of the car and and and how tells the
story of how we can go faster someday. Um so this
session review piece, specifically this view with
with tire information here, helps us understand
like how we're developing grip over the lap,
over a session. Um and and all this stuff is is
coming in automatically in the background and it's
ready within two or two or three minutes from post
session. Um, that's really the powerful thing is
is being able to just serve this information
up right away instead of our tire engineer,
for example, having to go and calculate these
reports and put this stuff together and then it
gets sent out 30 or 40 or 50 minutes later and
it gives us a significantly less amount of time
to take action upon it. How do you actually think
that's going to compare then? You mentioned they
like it could take 10, 20, like an hour tops to
actually coales this information. When you've got
these I mean we've got some great custom widgets
here that actually kind of show that information
in the format that your users your team are
familiar with. like in terms of the time cut down,
what do you expect like the impact of this is
going to be? I I think what what it really does
is it allows our our engineering group, you know,
his Kyle's race engineer and and Kyle to sit down
and and in five or six minutes as they sort
of debrief in detail with themselves from the
session to immediately go and like, hey, like what
happened with tire pressure? What happened with
the tire temperatures? You know, why did I have
this sensation of over steer after three or four
laps? Like what what was the temperature
distribution front to rear of the tires,
for example, or something? And it just serves
that information right away. So as they debrief
from the session, they can answer their own
questions right away. We we find that a lot
of times we we we just don't have time to look at
things like this, right? We we there's a lot of
important things to look at and it's kind of in in
order what you should be looking at. And a lot of
times some of this stuff falls behind. So having a
clearcut um informative place to just click on it,
review it within seconds, and then get out of
it and understand it is absolutely crucial for
between sessions, right? A lot of times we don't
find things until after a race or after a session
at night when engineers are staying up till
midnight looking at things. So um it's extremely
interesting and what we saw there in the previous
screen was actually some of your comments right
you've got the evolution of your comments coming
out of the car the changes that the engineers
have made as a result and then you can actually
see that outing to outing right so KL how do you
think about communicating with your team right I
know that there's a lot of nuance around like you
could say oh this doesn't feel great this doesn't
feel good but you're always thinking about how can
I give my team the right information for them
to take the right action so how do you think
about that when communicating with the team on
track of Of course. And and you you want to give
them simple um terms that they can understand
where you talked about over steer, under steer,
um things that are just going to help the balance
of the car that you know intuitively that that
will make it faster. And that that's kind of
just kind of the seat of the pants of the driver,
but you also want it to correlate directly with
what the data says. And um it's important that you
that you compare each one of those and understand
that because a lot of times you can find yourself
where the data completely contradicts what the
driver says. And that is a pretty disappointing
thing as a driver if I'm being honest. Um
because usually the data is right. So, so
you're always trying to wanting or you're always
wanting to match those things up. And when you do
match them up, which is 90% of the time I would
say, um you usually get good things out of it.
That's awesome. And on that note, talking of data
and like backing up your commentary, let's talk
sensors for a second. We've done a lot of work to
pull in all of the telemetry coming off the car.
I think this is amassed something like a quarter
of a trillion data points that we're working with
within the platform. Just got started. Just got
started. Yeah, this is like days weeks in. I we
actually ran this little experiment in Nashville
just last weekend when we saw that the time it
takes for you to walk from the timing stand on
the pit wall back to the garage. In that time,
all of that data is flowing off the car into the
platform and actually contextualizing within that
within that ontology ready to start working with.
So, Zach, I mean, that's firstly insane. It's just
so impressive we'd be able to do that so quickly.
How do you think that's going to transform the way
that Andretti operates? I mean, the big challenge,
especially with the time series data that we have,
is it comes in these big chunks, these big splats
between between outings. Uh, and there's over
2,000 channels of data in there and and much of
it is things that we don't necessarily need or
they are channels that are calculating something
that we need further downstream that help that
help us inform. You know, Kyle's talking about a
a high-speed imbalance and we go look at the the
center of pressure of the car and understand
where the aerero balance of the car is. Um,
and so making sure that that data is accurate
and is not having failing sensors or or missing
stuff. You know, these these are not gentle road
cars that drive around all day. These are race
cars that are smashed around the racetrack and
occasionally crash. And it's a never- ending
battle, unfortunately. It's a never- ending battle
to keep every sensor on the car in prime condition
and operating correctly. And and that's the the
biggest challenge of this kind of data. Yeah,
that's incredible. And K, I mean, I guess for you
as well, I think we've we've talked a lot about
how do we make sure that that data is in the best
possible form, right? Like everything's working,
you're getting all the telemetry you need. Like
how does that I guess that makes a massive impact
for you, right? When you have those that stuff to
hand ready to use as quickly as possible. Yeah,
certainly. Right. And there's always questions
whether the data that you're looking at is correct
or or incorrect, and you're always basing it off
of multiple other sensors kind of around the car
to just correlate and tie the whole picture
together. So, um, yeah, you you and that goes
back to what I'm talking about like in between
sessions where you look at one thing, you're like,
"Okay, I see this is what's happening, but what
what is happening here and what's happening here?"
And you're always you're always kind of tying
the whole picture together. So, to to have a
data point that is that you know is accurate
and you know you can trust is something that
also saves time for us, right? And and it's very
important for performance. That's awesome. And I
think the big thing for us, and I know I've been
working with the team a lot on this, is okay, it's
one thing seeing the data. It's one thing having
visibility, but it's really about being proactive
around like what can we alert upon, like what can
we actually push to the team proactively to say,
hey, this is something you should take a look at.
So, I mean, tell me the story, Zach. We built this
tire pressure and monitoring system workflow,
right, where we were building off some of those
tire sensors that we're working with to actually
identify anomalies and even like something around
battery levels, right? So, tell me a bit of the
story about how this workflow came to be. Yeah,
we we were at Toronto uh and and struggling.
Actually, Kyle's car specifically in a session
had a TPMS sensor that failed. Um and that that
that sensor tells us not just the tire pressure,
but tire temperatures and all kinds of things that
represent performance. Um and when that fails,
that that's a huge bit of information that he
doesn't have, that we don't have that we can't
make decisions on. So, uh uh Joe and and the group
kind of overheard this challenge. And because we
were already scooping the data up, because we were
already parsing it and and doing all the things
we were, they in about 24 hours, we're able to to
push this app out to our systems engineers to help
them see the status of every sensor that's ever
been on the car, when the last time it was run,
all the times it was run, what its battery
level was, and a little prediction of of when
that battery might get to a place where they got
to take it out of service. And and truthfully,
since then, since Toronto, Kyle's not had a single
TPMS problem on the car because of this app. We've
we've been able to to to peel the sensors out at
the right time and replace them with new ones.
That's awesome. And I think it also speaks to
a little bit of our approach of building with
Andretti, especially in these last few weeks where
once you get that foundational ontology down, the
ability to very quickly stand up new solutions,
new apps, like we hear a bit of feedback from the
team, we implement it 24 hours later or even
less. Like it's kind of enabling the team to
move faster, right? Like obviously challenges
are always showing up and the nature of your
performance on track, the evolution of the season,
the team is constantly evolving, right? So,
it's a little bit like how do we keep pace with
that and build to exactly what the team needs at
any given point, right? Yeah. And I and I think
like things like this, our systems engineers are
really good. They're really bright. They they they
keep the car in a really good running condition,
but there are so many sensors and there's so much
stuff that humans are bound to miss something. But
if we if we can peel them up and and and serve
them better information sooner, they're happier.
Awesome. That's perfect. So to wrap us up, I think
we're going to be talking a little bit about some
of that anomaly detection. Like what are those
things that we spot where okay, obviously the the
tire battery stuff, pretty simple, like go change
this, go solve this problem. I think as you start
to talk about identifying those sensor anomalies
and those sort of behaviors that are maybe harder
to deduce like what exactly is going on, we're
building more of a sort of investigation workflow
around that, right? So I guess like Zach, tell
me a little bit more about how like when you see
that behavior like how did you work with that data
previously? How would you go through that process?
And as we see in the demo, like how is that going
to change when building a palenteer? Yeah. So, so
the the current workflow would be every time a a
data file comes off the car, the systems engineer
is going to page through very quickly by eye and
just make sure that all the critical sensors, all
the things that we were testing, everything was
working and in working order. And they're humans,
so we're going to miss things. Um, so if we
can add some some machine learning on top of
that to help flag things that that h that maybe
just failed for a split second on a lap that we
weren't particularly looking at, we can flag that
to go investigate eventually. Uh, I I think that's
that's really powerful. And then from there, we
can drill down into like here's all the anomalies
we saw. Here's how many of them there were. Here's
the corner they keep showing up on. You know, can
we can we flag that for someone else to follow up
with later. Is there a a build of the car that we
have to move around in a different way uh to to to
prevent these problems from happening? And I think
that's the that's the beauty of of this deeper
dive. That's awesome. And it's actually a perfect
segue as we sort of start to wrap up thinking
about 2026, right, Carl? As I mentioned, solid
performance this championship really exciting to
see the speed that the team's moving at. How does
that set you up for the 26 season, right? Like
what some of the focuses, what's top of mind for
you in terms of improvement. Yeah. What does the
the next few months look like in the offseason?
Well, we're in a constantly evolving sport. You
always need to progress. You always need to get
better. And we have a long time to do that now.
And and things like this will help us immensely.
And for me as a driver, I'm always just trying
to figure out, okay, what what is our what is our
best tracks? Yeah. How do we improve on that? How
do we continue down this route? And then also what
is our worst tracks and how can we adjust to make
those better? So, um that's really the the topic
of of focus um for the offseason for us. Awesome.
And Zach, final remarks from you. What are you
most excited about looking forward to the next 12
months with Palanteer? I I think the the workflows
that we can build that we can uh take some time
away, get our race engineers specifically to go
to bed a little earlier and not be staying up so
late so they're not so cranky the next morning. Um
and and and help them make better decisions cuz
winning races is why we're here. That's awesome.
Well, K's going to be upset I got him up bright
and early for little pre-show. But honestly,
guys, thank you so much for joining us. This
has been great fun. Great to work through all
the work that we've built so far in just a few
short weeks. I've never been more excited for
the next season. Honestly, it's only the start,
too. It's only the start, literally. Um, well,
with that, thank you so much, everyone at home for
tuning in. This is only the start of the show. Do
not go anywhere. Thank you so much for joining
us. This is AIPCON 8. Thank you for watching.